politique
bonsoir et bienvenue dans l'hebdos
politiques votre rendez-vous politique
du dimanche soir sur Radio sensation en
association avec TV 78 épisode de 238 ce
soir mon invité et Ghislaine Séné la
présidente du pôle écologiste à la
région
Île-de-France
[Musique]
merci d'être avec nous ce soir dans
l'hebdopolitique vous êtes conseillère
régional d'Île-de-France depuis 2010
c'est membre d'Europe Écologie Les Verts
depuis 2009 alors on va revenir avec
vous sur cette semaine riche en
événement politique le gouvernement a
finalement activé le 49-3 pour faire
passer la réforme des retraites à
l'Assemblée nationale alors que il avait
dit pendant plusieurs semaines que ce
n'était pas une option les observateurs
parlent de crise politique démocratique
crise sociale aussi est-ce que vous
partagez ces termes absolument
crise crise démocratique certainement
puisque enfin on ne peut pas c'est assez
inédit de gouverner avec un mode aussi
aussi autoritaire
début du deuxième quinquennat d'Emmanuel
Macron tout à fait et puis crise sociale
parce que on voit bien que le dialogue
social n'a pas eu n'a pas eu lieu enfin
c'est quand même exceptionnel d'avoir
une inter syndicale aussi soudée aussi
forte et le choix politique à ce
moment-là me semble incroyablement
risqué puisque ça ne fait que renforcer
finalement les les revendications de
l'ensemble des travailleurs mais surtout
de l'ensemble d'une grande majorité des
Français qui aujourd'hui refusent cette
réforme alors ce 49 3 il permet donc de
faire passer des projets de loi sans
l'accord sans le vote du Parlement le 49
3 justement le député Europe Écologie
Les Verts Jérémy Yordanov élu en Isère a
déposé justement une proposition de loi
constitutionnelle le 9 mars 2023 pour
notamment supprimer cet article 49-3 de
la Constitution aujourd'hui cette
situation vous conforte aussi dans cette
conviction Europe Écologie les verres
absolument les 49 c'était plutôt pour
pour forcer sa majorité enfin on parle
beaucoup de l'utilisation du
49-3 et notamment au moment de
l'instauration du RMI oui là c'était
parce que il y avait une vraie volonté
de pouvoir apporter socialement et donc
forcer la majorité à accepter ce nouveau
projet de société or là on est
finalement complètement à l'inverse et
pour c'est pour museler l'opposition et
c'est pour passer en force malgré
l'opinion l'opinion publique alors la
suite maintenant la semaine prochaine ce
sera sûrement les émotions de censure
qui seront très certainement étudiées
demain elle pourrait éventuellement
renverser le gouvernement si elles
étaient adoptées tout dépendra du choix
des députés LR qui n'ont pas souhaité
voter donc en partie la réforme des
retraites est-ce que vous y croyez vous
à ces motion de censure côté j'avoue que
voilà on est au là on ne ça devient
vraiment de la politique de la politique
fiction enfin j'ai entendu un monsieur
cioti ce matin qui appelle à ce que
effectivement ne met pas plus de chaos
que skin ce qui n'existe à ce stade moi
je pense que c'est chaque député en son
nom et conscience qui devra prendre
cette cette décision mais en tout cas ce
qui est certain c'est que on voit qu'il
faut absolument revoir notre
Constitution il faut il faut revoir ce
modèle démocratique pour pour faire en
sorte que que la France qui a toujours
brillé sur sur ces questions puissent
faire en sorte que effectivement ce soir
bien
pour le peuple et par le peuple que que
voilà on puisse en tout cas
ressouder refonder un projet de société
qui est du sens parce qu'aujourd'hui on
sent qu'il y a vraiment une crise une
crise démocratique la solution à court
terme c'est le changement de
gouvernement c'est
valborne qui serait le fusible alors moi
je sais pas si c'est c'est la bonne
solution parce que si Emmanuel Macron
reste campé sur sur son idéologie et sur
sa volonté absolument de faire passer
une réforme qui n'est pas acceptée par
le français je sais même pas si c'est on
nous remet quelqu'un d'autre pour faire
défendre le même projet en fait on n'y
arrivera pas moi ce qui me semble
important c'est c'est c'est faire un
appel démocratique c'est c'est mettre en
place le référendum c'est c'est demander
la vie l'opinion aux Français on voit il
y a des nouvelles méthodes qui ont
émergé d'ailleurs Emmanuel Macron l'a
fait au travers de la convention
citoyenne mettons en place des nouveaux
dispositifs démocratiques qui permettent
effectivement et à la fois d'expliquer
ce que l'on souhaite faire et à la fois
de justifier parce que en fait la vraie
le vrai problème de cette réforme de
retraite c'est que tout le monde pense
qu'elle est inutile et en tout cas non
justifié on a aujourd'hui un déficit a
priori 2030 de 13 de 13 milliards et
parallèlement on a l'annonce de Total
qui fait un bénéfice de 19 milliards
dont 13 milliards c'est à dire
exactement la même somme qui vont
distribuer aux actionnaires enfin dans
la tête de n'importe quel citoyen on se
dit mais en fait on va nous nous obliger
à travailler deux ans de plus alors qu'à
côté dans une seule année en fait on va
distribuer le même montant à quelques à
quelques privilégiés en fait
il y a un tel décalage qu'il faut
aujourd'hui redonner du son s'il faut
expliquer les raisons pour lesquelles et
voilà il souhaite il souhaite agir et
2030 aujourd'hui avec toutes les
incertitudes qui sont devant nous face à
la crise climatique et à tous les enjeux
qui qui qui qui qui sont qui sont face à
nous et bien on se dit que un c'est pas
une priorité et de c'est se demander
pourquoi aujourd'hui on doit travailler
2 ans de plus alors que la productivité
augmente et que les entreprises du CAC
40 vivent aujourd'hui très bien alors
depuis vendredi les les blocages les
actions de les coups de force sont
multipliés notamment on a vu aussi des
préfectures être attaqués vandalisés il
reste encore quatre ans de quinquennat
est-ce que tout justifie enfin est-ce
que la colère justifie ses actions
non alors moi je crois que en fait le
rôle des de la puissance publique des
pouvoirs publics c'est de faire en sorte
que cette colère n'existe pas c'est à
dire c'est faire en sorte d'apporter des
solutions c'est à dire faire en sorte
que il n'y ait pu cette fracture qu'il
n'y ait pu autant de d'inégalités entre
le travailleur du quotidien
chez nous garder cette exception
française finalement est-ce que c'est
notre pays a toujours été une exception
et je pense que c'est ça qui fait sa
force et c'est ça qui fait sa richesse
et ça qui fait sa grandeur et je crois
que enfin les seuls
a eu la révolution à française on est on
est porteur d'un certain nombre de de de
grandes valeurs de principe de
solidarité il y a peu de de pays qui a
une retraite répartition qui a la
sécurité sociale enfin soit ils ont
fiers et défendons justement cette
spécificité et arrêtons de nous comparer
quand ça arrange avec avec les autres
avec les autres pays je crois que on a
aujourd'hui une échéance qui est posée
au travers d'un rapport qui a
effectivement montré que pendant
quelques années il y allait avoir
difficile et bien trouvons
collectivement les bonnes décisions et
et surtout ne passons pas en force on ne
peut pas imposer à 9 actifs sur 10
puisque 9 actifs sur 10 refusent c'est
très fort continuer à travailler deux
ans de plus il y a un sondage aussi qui
m'a marqué cette semaine un sondage Ifop
60% des salariés de moins de 35 ans
souhaitent démissionner ou changer de
métier alors un chiffre assez
préoccupant c'est quoi le problème ce
sont les conditions de travail qui ne
cesse de se dégrader on a de moins en
moins d'avantages avec les nouveaux
contrats ou au contraire c'est cette
génération finalement de jeunes qui est
différente des autres et qui aspirent à
un autre projet de vie moi je crois je
crois même enfin depuis le début je
parle de sens quel sens on donne notre
vie quoi est-ce que notre vie c'est de
travailler constamment pour pouvoir
consommer toujours plus pour finalement
n'être pas plus heureux et pour pouvoir
continuer à consommer il faut continuer
à travailler plus enfin on est dans un
modèle qui ne fonctionne pas d'autant
plus qu'on sait que derrière ça engendre
l'effondrement de la biodiversité
le réchauffement climatique qui fait que
on va avoir des conditions de vie de
plus en plus compliquées donc on a une
nouvelle génération que moi je ne pense
pas différente mais qui au contraire
est certainement plus politisée et et
s'interroge sur sur sur son devenir et
n'a pas envie de subir des décisions de
vieux ou moins vieux monsieur à la tête
d'un étain et qui continue à regarder
ses tableaux ces chiffres et continuent
à avancer en essayant de de voilà de
remplir les bons ratios et d'avoir les
meilleurs notes pour pour pouvoir
montrer à quel point il a été efficace
et bonne élève je pense qu'il faut qu'on
sorte de ça et la réalité c'est qu'on a
aujourd'hui une jeunesse qui n'a pas
envie de travailler pour rien qui n'a
pas envie de travailler sans donner du
sens à ce que ce qu'il fait et je crois
que c'est c'est un vrai un vrai
phénomène de de société qu'il faut
aujourd'hui entendre l'actualité à
l'Assemblée nationale cette semaine
c'était aussi le débat sur le nucléaire
de de retour le gouvernement souhaite
relancer la filière nucléaire après un
temps de pause l'énergie nucléaire à
l'avantage d'être décarbonée elle
n'aimait pas de CO2 alors pourquoi chez
Europe Écologie Les Verts on ne souhaite
pas développer cette filière alors
historiquement on a on a toujours un des
fondamentaux du parti europécologie les
Verts c'est c'est et des Verts c'est
c'est effectivement
enfin l'ortie nucléaire être
anti-nucléaire pourquoi parce que on
considère que c'est pas une énergie sur
le long terme on considère qu'il y a la
problématique des déchets la
problématique de la sécurité et des
nouvelles problématiques qui arrivent un
obsolescence de plus en plus flagrante
et on a encore découvert tout récemment
une énorme fissure encore sur sur une
sur une une des centrales donc avec donc
du du matériel vieillissant et puis des
nouvelles difficultés c'est à dire que
pour que le nucléaire est centrales
nucléaire puisse fonctionner
correctement sans mettre en danger la
vie des gens il faut de l'eau pour
refroidir les réacteurs et on sait que
la ressource en eau devient de plus en
plus une ressource rare à sauvegarder
et donc on a et je ne parle pas de
l'uranium et de tout ce que ça peut
engendrer comme comme crise géo
géopolitique et donc le vrai sujet c'est
qu'on pense que ce n'est pas une une
énergie sur sur le long terme et c'est
même une énergie qui a eu de vrai
travers un faire en sorte que la France
est complètement en retard dans le
développement des énergies renouvelables
enfin je veux dire on est l'un des seuls
pays européens de pas voir
atteint ses objectifs ça c'est la
première la première raison et deux on
continue à faire comme si il était
normal qu'on surconsomme de l'énergie et
c'est pour ça qu'on va aller créer la 5G
parce que aujourd'hui très concrètement
nous ne pouvons pas vivre sans 5G enfin
je veux dire c'est on serait le pays
vraiment en perte de vitesse si nous
n'avions pas de 5g c'est en tout cas ce
qu'on essaie de nous faire croire on a
on essaie de nous faire croire qu'on a
besoin d'un téléphone avec
une image 3D qui apparaissent et qui
permet de pouvoir régler tout tous nos
problèmes avec le congélateur le truc
qui nous dit ah là là on va commander
mais bouge pas ça va venir tu sais voilà
c'est c'est le monde qu'on nous prépare
et qui va surconsommer de l'énergie on
nous propose aussi pour régler les
problèmes de mobilité et les problèmes
de démission de gaz à effet de serre les
problèmes de particules fines et bien
plutôt c'est arrêter la voiture énergie
fossile pour pouvoir faire une voiture
tout électrique et en fait à chaque fois
on va trouver une nouvelle solution
technologique plutôt que de répondre aux
vrais problèmes c'est dire comment on
règle la question de la mobilité et la
mobilité ça passe forcément par des
questions d'aménagement par des
questions de comment on arrive à refaire
revenir les commerces les activités au
plus près en fait des des lieux de vie
donc on a énormément en fait de sujets
sur lequel il faut se poser et et et et
poser le vrai problème de fond plutôt
que dire dans les bougez pas il y a ça
on va trouver une solution et toutes les
solutions aujourd'hui sont tournées en
tout cas en France sur l'énergie
électrique et donc on nous dit pour ça
il faut forcément multiplier du
nucléaire l'Assemblée nationale a
supprimé en tout cas l'objectif de
réduction à 50% de la part de l'énergie
nucléaire dans le mix énergétique
français d'ici à 2035 c'était un verrou
introduit dans la loi en 2015 sous la
présidence de François Hollande pour
réduire justement cette part du
nucléaire pour vous elle doit être à
zéro cette part d'une nucléaire quel mix
énergétique alors alternative
proposez-vous actuellement et en tout
cas au centre de d'Europe Écologie Les
Verts il y a des discussions on a
aujourd'hui des militants qui sont de
plus en plus en train de s'interroger
parce que effectivement l'urgence du
réchauffement climatique et là bien là
nous on pensait qu'elle allait venir
beaucoup plus tard tardivement et puis
en fait on s'est rendu compte que tout
s'accélérait donc on a on a aujourd'hui
un vrai débat à avoir moi je crois que
toutes les critiques toutes les craintes
tout toutes les risques que portent
aujourd'hui le nucléaire nous pousse à
penser que non il faut effectivement
réussir à
progressivement pour arriver au zéro
nucléaire dans les dans les dans les
années à venir et on l'a vu lors de les
présidentielles notre candidat Yannick
Jadot a annoncé qu'effectivement
finalement on diminué beaucoup plus
lentement et on devrait arriver à 0
nucléaire dans les en 2050
la question c'est et que personne ne
pose aujourd'hui et qui n'est pas dans
les débats c'est c'est la question de la
sobriété l'atténuation et c'est ce que
je disais tout à l'heure c'est quelle
solution apporte pour faire en sorte que
aujourd'hui on consomme beaucoup moins
d'énergie et que non la vie ou le
développement de de de la société ne
doit pas dépendre de de la consommation
de la consommation électrique et donc
aujourd'hui le vrai question qui se pose
c'est quel modèle là encore de société
nous souhaitons il y a le scénario
Negawatt qui démontre que on peut et à
la fois descendre en matière d'énergie
enfin de d'arrêter la consommation
d'énergie fossiles et du nucléaire en
développant un certain nombre d'actions
au travers du développement des énergies
renouvelables et surtout au travers de
de nouvelles technologies qui
l'hydrogène par exemple et puis et puis
surtout la sobriété en fait il y a un
mix énergétique à trouver mais nous
continuons à penser que oui le nucléaire
le nucléaire doit être une énergie qui
qui au fur et à mesure doit être
abandonnée
régionale l'hebdopolitique
[Musique]
toujours avec Ghislaine Séné présidente
du pôle écologiste à la région
Île-de-France les éboueurs de Paris sont
toujours en grève les Parisiens voient
des tonnes et des tonnes d'ordures
samassées sur les trottoirs les éboueurs
se mobilisent contre la réforme des
retraites même si leurs grèves entraîne
de lourdes inconvénients pour les
parisiens et peuvent aussi entraîner des
problèmes sanitaires est-ce que c'est
une mobilisation finalement responsable
cette grève des éboueurs
la responsabilité vient du gouvernement
qui veut passer en force une réforme qui
n'a pas lieu d'être en fait enfin un
moment donné faut arrêter de rejeter la
responsabilité sur les personnes qui
sont un travail quotidien indispensable
pénible difficile et à qui on est en
train de dire bon ben voilà vous aurez à
travailler deux ans de plus alors il y a
la question du service public la
question des services
pas que on puisse dire que dans le cadre
du service public il puisse y avoir
effectivement
réquisition en tout cas s'assurer que le
service a un service minimum soit mis en
place ça ça me choque absolument pas ça
me choque pas dans les transports ça me
choque pas non plus mais le vrai sujet
c'est c'est organisons là encore le
dialogue social pour arriver à de tels
mesures et ne pas
vouloir aller en force et puis au
dernier moment alors que on se rend
compte en fait que oui sans ces gens-là
sans ces personnes qui vont aller
ramasser les poubelles qui vont aller
garder les enfants qui vont aller
soigner et laver les les personnes
malades mais en fait la société ne
tourne pas donc considérant les
considérons les pourraient faire face au
gouvernement à ordonner des réquisitions
pour vider donc les poubelles qui
s'entassent dans la capitale la
préfecture de police doit désormais
publier un arrêté préfectoral ce
week-end des notifié aux agents
concernés leur réquisition est-ce que la
préfecture de police est dans son rôle
est-ce qu'elle peut faire autrement
est-ce qu'elle devrait pas selon vous
effectuer ces réquisitions ce que je
disais à l'instant c'est à dire que
arrivé devant devant le fait accompli
ben ouais voilà c'est ce qui va se
passer et donc ça veut dire qu'on va
encore
attaquer des libertés individuelles et
on va dire à telle personne toi tu vas
être obligé de tu vas être obligé de
travailler mais parce qu'on est arrivé
au bout de au bout du bout qui a eu
aucune aucune anticipation et c'est là
encore le rôle des personnes qui qui
sont à la tête d'un gouvernement de
pouvoir anticiper sur ces sur ces
choses-là dans les grands mouvements de
grève on a toujours connu cela on a
toujours finalement connu cela et on a
eu des fois des des périodes très très
dures enfin en 85 il y a vraiment eu des
des moments où toutes l'économie a été a
été bloquée et bien il y a eu des
moments où les gouvernements ont pris
leur responsabilité ont pris leur
responsabilité et ont décidé que oui ce
n'était plus possible d'avoir autant de
déchets dans la rue c'était le plus
possible de ne plus avoir de transport
pour que les gens puissent aller
travailler et donc et ben pour ça il
faut négocier mais ça veut dire qu'il la
forêt réinstaurer le dialogue social et
le rapport de force le tourisme la
région Île-de-France a développé les
chiffres pour l'année 2022 avec 44
millions de touristes la région
Île-de-France résiste bien malgré
l'absence quasi-totale encore des la
clientèle asiatique qui est en
particulier chinois ce qui représentait
l'habitude 1,5 millions de visiteurs le
nombre de touristes ne recule que de
moins 13% par rapport à 2019 l'année
référence avant la pandémie elkovid
contre -37 globalement au niveau mondial
est-ce que c'est une chance selon vous
pour la région Île-de-France cette
attractivité touristique et le fait
qu'elle attire autant de visiteurs
la région Île-de-France en fait le
tourisme a toujours été effectivement
une des activités économiques les plus
les plus importantes moi je vous dirais
est-ce qu'il faut vraiment s'en réjouir
j'en suis pas certaine parce que là
encore je ne suis pas certaine que ça
réponde en fait un modèle alors que des
des touristes étrangers viennent visiter
la France parce que et Paris de France
parce que parce que c'est un pays
merveilleux ça je peux le comprendre et
je crois qu'on peut pas on peut pas
interdire cela par contre peut-être là
encore posons-nous la question sur sur
ce tourisme de masse qui qui par avion
en fait en vendre énormément de de CO2
et que lorsque on met en place une
stratégie nationale bas carbone avec des
objectifs 0 carbone là encore à 2050 et
bien on pourrait se poser la question de
est-ce qu'il faut continuer à favoriser
ce type de tourisme là ou alors il faut
trouver un tourisme de proximité et qui
permet et à la fois de valoriser le
patrimoine et à la fois aussi de
permettre et bien toutes les personnes
qui n'ont pas forcément la chance de
partir en vacances de pouvoir et bien
voilà découvrir ce qui se passe à côté
de et toutes les belles choses qu'il y a
à côté de de chez eux et des visiteurs
étrangers il va y en avoir pour les Jeux
Olympiques en 2024 l'organisation avance
doucement mais sûrement vous avez vu
j'imagine comme beaucoup le prix des
pour assister donc aux épreuves des Jeux
Olympiques jugés par beaucoup très
élevés bien loin de l'image des jeux
populaires vendus au départ lors de
lorsqu'on a appris que la France allait
accueillir ces Jeux Olympiques est-ce
que c'était prévisible c'est
l'écologie on l'avait on était certain
parce que c'est ce qui s'est passé enfin
quand on regarde dans les autres dans
les autres pays à Londres en
l'occurrence on savait que de toute
façon
avec la crise qui était en train de de
de se jouer ces jeux là
n'étaient pas pour nous à notre sens pas
le bon moment je pense qu'il y a eu un
vrai moi je crois qu'il y a vraiment une
vraie forme de cynisme en fait sur sur
ces JO on sait que là encore le modèle
économique tourne autour de la
consommation des sponsors enfin on va en
faire tout un tout un plat la réalité
c'est que dans les quartiers les plus
populaires on est en train de se poser
la question de comment faire en sorte de
sortir les familles pour pouvoir libérer
plus de place pour que les familles ne
soient pas dans les transports en commun
parce qu'on va avoir un problème de
transport en commun et donc on est
absolument pas sur des jeux qui sont qui
sont inclusivement je trouve ça
totalement scandaleux parce que oui il
faut avoir de grandes manifestations
sportives oui parce que ça permet à
chacun de pouvoir s'évader de pouvoir
voilà se pousser à faire du sport mais
pas avec un modèle qui aujourd'hui
impose à ce qui est des mesures de
sécurité impose des normes qui font
qu'aujourd'hui on détruit la
biodiversité l'île de loisirs vers Torcy
j'y étais encore la semaine dernière on
a été rasé toutes les roselières alors
qu'il y a des espèces protégées tout ça
parce que sinon la caméra
on aurait pu la monter on aurait pu
utiliser les drones non en fait la
caméra ça ne correspondait pas aux
normes olympiques et donc il faut tout
raser alors qu'on nous a promis là
encore ça allait être inclusif et que ça
allait être très très respectueux de
l'environnement donc en fait on aurait
eu tout intérêt nous la France comme
pays d'afficher et d'affir
j'ai toujours utile j'ai tout
investissement et toute réflexion qui
permet de pouvoir diminuer les missions
gaz à effet de serre je pense que
voilà la problème c'est que là on est
dans dans la compensation c'est à dire
qu'on génère et après on essaie de
trouver des solutions à posteriori en
fait l'idéal c'est de ne pas générer
c'est ces nouveaux ces nouveaux gaz à
effet de serre et donc il y a un juste
équilibre à trouver et il faut arrêter
d'utiliser l'outil de compensation parce
que on le voit et notamment sur la
question de la biodiversité ce n'est
absolument pas à la hauteur des
objectifs que lorsque on va aller
bétonner un espace naturel on va aller
renaturer à ce stade et la définition
vous savez sur le zéro artificialisation
net et tous les choses ne sont pas
encore très claires mais on va renaturer
un espace qui est déjà naturel
on a
été très longtemps à IDFM aussi enfin on
bétonné d'un côté et ensuite on disait
oui mais on compense dans la forêt qui
est là on va l'entretenir la forêt face
au que la forêt c'était déjà un espace
naturel il y avait déjà de la
biodiversité dedans qui était peut-être
pas au top du top mais c'était déjà un
espace naturel c'est ce système de de
compensation nous dire qu'on prend
session piège à con c'est c'est vraiment
aujourd'hui ce qui est
l'illustration parfaite de de d'une
hypocrisie qui dit non non mais on
continue comme avant mais vous inquiétez
pas on va on va améliorer le système et
on voit bien que non les fondrement de
la biodiversité en l'occurrence et leur
échauffement climatique est en train
encore de de continuer merci beaucoup
Ghislaine d'avoir été avec nous
je rappelle donc que vous êtes la
présidente du pôle écologiste à la
région Île-de-France nous on se retrouve
la semaine prochaine pour un nouveau
numéro de l'hebdo politique sur Radio
sensation très bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]